Down.
Okay. Hello everybody. Let's go ahead
and open up the doors to our Zoom room
if we could please. My wonderful
co-hosts. Folks, if you are watching us
on one of our live streams and you would
like to join us here on dailywithdoc,
you are more than welcome to by coming
to dailywith doc zoom. So that's a
dailywithdoczoom.com.
Come on over and if you have questions
folks and you're here in the zoom with
us, go ahead and find that raise hand
option. go to the Zoom menu, look for
reactions, and raise hand because I will
be calling on people who have their
hands raised. If you can't raise your
hand or you're out on one of the other
social media type platforms, you can
write questions in the comments also as
my amazing co-hosts are helping me to
monitor those different platforms and
bring those questions to the table so
that we can get answers from the great
doctor that we have with us today. and
every Monday through Friday from 12 to
12:50 p.m. Pacific time. My name is
Becca Dukes and as the hostess of this
program, I am honored to be able to
bring to you something that brought me
back my life that allowed me to be able
to go from just barely survive. Folks,
listen up. You are in for some
information that I had never heard. Yes,
I had heard just eat right and that's
all you need to do. I had heard about
this supplement being good for this and
this supplement being good for this
which I have learned is called
fractionated supplementation.
Well, based on decades of research
of the doctor that we have with us
today, your body needs 90 essential
nutrients
all together. Not one here, not one
there. You put it all together and the
body gets the raw ingredients that it
needs each and every time so that it can
do what it was designed to do and that
is to thrive and function properly. So
if you're not thriving and functioning
properly, you're definitely in the right
place. you're also in the right place
here with dailywithdoc.
This program is being sponsored by
dailywithdoc.com
where we have the good foods bad foods
list that Dr. Wallick will be mentioning
many times. So when he goes through all
the good things to stay away from, let
me correct that. When he goes through
all the bad things to stay away from and
you can't write fast enough, fear not.
We have them at dailywithdoc.com.
We also have replays from our past
episodes, including some specials that
I've done with Dr. Wallik and also
pharmacist Ben Fuches using nutrition
folks so that the body can thrive. And
we also have a store there. So all the
products that you hear about today,
you'll be able to find in our store on
dailywithdoc.com
specific. I want you to make sure that
you get back with them to order. I want
also want you to get back with them,
please, and thank them for sharing this
program with you because we are a
resource for an amazing community of
folks who have found what I found, maybe
a little bit, maybe a lot, maybe more
than what I received as far as gaining
my health back.
they're in this crusade with us. So, we
want to make sure that if they share
information with somebody that that
person gets back with them so that they
can be the
coach
that that person needs to find what is
going to be the best fit for them so
that they can reach their goals as well.
If you are here live with us, please
please go ahead and raise your hand
early as we do fill up with questions
and we do stop right at 12:50 so that
Dr. Wlet can get on to his next program.
So, it is my honor and privilege to
bring to the screen with me Dr. Dr. Joel
Wallik who has a bachelor of science in
agriculture studying plants and soils, a
doctorate of veterary medicine going on
to you know working with actual live
breathing beings. Wait, plants breathe
too. They're alive. So let's just go
with mammals and amphibians and reptiles
and all those things that vet exotic and
domestic veterinarians take care of. and
three postdoates in pathology. And if
that wasn't enough, after teaching
nutrition at the college level, he
became a naturopathic physician so that
he could actually talk to us and nobody
could say, "Well, you're not a doctor.
Why should I listen to you?" Well,
folks, he is a doctor. He's also one of
the founding fathers of the science
genetics. So listen up because Doc,
epigenetics was the light that gave me
hope. Of all those things that I was
told were genetic and I'd have to just
live with the rest of my life was a lie.
So what do you have to share with us
today, Dr. Wallik?
>> Well, more the truth. The truth is
wonderful. Thanks for sharing your
personal story. Okay. And so I love the
truth. And uh today I want to talk about
skin. Everybody has skin. And in America
alone each year just to treat symptoms,
okay, of skin issues, not makeup or
cosmetics or anything like that, but but
doctor prescribed treatments. We spend
$75 billion dollars a year just to treat
skin issues. We're talking about
cortisone, prennazone,
um antibiotics, all kinds of stuff that
they put on the skin for skin issues.
and they're really not pushing the right
buttons. Okay, you'll get some relief,
but you're not getting down to the basic
root cause of the problem.
And to, you know, kind of give you a
perspective, Parkinson's disease, okay,
very, very dangerous
disease and human beings and we're
working on that one, too. Um, but we
spent $52 billion a year just to treat
the symptoms of Parkinson's disease. And
we spend $75 billion a year just to
treat skin symptoms.
Okay. So, what's going on here? Well,
everybody has skin. It covers your
entire outside body. It helps you
control your body temperature, keeping
it where it's optimal. Okay? You sweat
if you need to get rid of some heat. Um,
but you got to watch it because you do
need to keep taking in fluid so you
don't get dehydrated. You're not taking
in all 90 essential nutrients as Rebecca
was talking about. You start getting
wrinkles. Uh, you start getting
blisters. You started getting ulcers.
You start getting
bugs that start jumping on the skin
that's not you start getting cracker
cracker cracks. You start getting
cracks, okay, in your skin. and um you
look like you're 25 years older than you
really are, okay? Because you're missing
nutrients. And so this is not difficult.
Again, a hair analysis is a good way to
find out where you're at with the
nutritional minerals, also with the
toxic minerals. Okay? And so I like a
hair analysis
um as opposed to taking biopsies because
you're going to get a limited amount of
information from a surgical biopsy of
the skin. Okay?
um if they're suspicious of a skin
cancer
uh in a small you know it's like the
diameter of a um a pee or a quarter or
something like that they can actually
surgically remove it okay you know with
a kind of a a safe place around the
lesion so that you get it all and oh
good is it wasn't a cancer thing and so
these are the sort of approaches we're
talking about here $75 billion a year
for that. Okay. How many nutrients does
your skin need? Needs 90 essentials of
nutrients just like your heart, just
like your lungs, just like your
intestines, just like your bones, just
like your brain. Okay? And so, um,
people who think, well, I just eat well
and I, you know, I'm getting everything
I need. My doctor said, I just hate that
when people say that, my doctor said.
Well, if we gave your doctor a test,
they probably wouldn't pass the test
when it came to nutrition. Okay? And so,
this is something that we as individuals
have to participate, okay? In taking
care of our skin. Now, the skin uh can
defend against bugs, viruses, bacteria,
fungus, and yeast and parasites. The
skin again protects you from cold. And
of course, um, you get clues. Uh, you
start losing your hair. You start, um,
getting cracks and and ulcers and
wrinkles in your skin. Uh, if you're a
person of color, you might start
getting, uh, loss of skin color. And it
might just look, you know, look like
somebody just took a a brush full of
white paint and kind of threw it at you.
So, you're getting these little white
dots all over you because you're not
able to produce the skin color
everywhere like you should, okay, to
maintain your your um skin color. And
and this is not difficult to which I say
diagnose. So, you don't have to have
three PhD degrees to diagnose it. And
that's why we came up with these various
books. dead doctors don't lie. We came
up with epigenetics. We came up with um
rare earth spin cures. these including
the skin.
And when you have stuff going on with
the skin, uh it's kind of like again the
red warning light on your damage or your
car because the nutritional deficiencies
that are causing your problems in your
skin are also causing problems in your
bones and your cartilage, your ligaments
and tendons and your heart and your
lungs and your liver, your intestines,
your kidneys and um your brain and your
eyes and so on. So the the same things
that are causing skin problems are
causing other things. So your skin can
be looked at as a red warning light like
we have on the dashboard of the car.
Okay. Now um I want to talk about the 90
essential nutrients, 60 zero minerals,
16 vitamins, 12 mineral three fatty
acids. Our skin needs all of those every
day to maintain itself because it's
busy. He's got all these things it's
doing to to maintain your health and
optimal levels, okay? Uh to fend off the
bad guys, okay? You need your skin to be
in good shape.
And so if you're missing one or two or
three or four or five out of the 60, uh
that come on, only I'm only missing
five. I still have the other 55. No,
that's not good. Okay? You don't want to
do that. Don't don't even think that
way. Okay? And so we have um again our
basic core program. So let's start
there. Very very economical. Our basic
core program, our healthy start pack. It
has 90 essential nutrients in it. Okay.
60 minerals, 16 vitamins, famines, three
fatty acids, the basic stuff that your
skin and all other tissues and systems
require. Um healthy start pack. And then
I like to throw in
the because skin is um uh collagen,
okay? It's it's like tendons and
ligaments. It's the same tissues as
tendons and ligaments and cartilage and
so forth. So in addition to the healthy
start pack, I like to throw in the I
like to throw in the MSM. Per 100 pounds
of body weight, you want to take one
bottle a month of the MSN. take three
twice a day and it will um help you um
support repair and replacement of dead
connective tissue including your bone
marrow, your skin, uh that kind of
thing. So, it's imperative that you
think in those terms. Then I also like
the collagen peptides. The collagen
peptides, it has collagen from fish,
poultry, sheep, and beef. Uh, you know,
you want to scoop of that with your
morning drink and screw with your
evening drink. Comes in powder. And um,
we also want you to think in terms of
um, things you put on your skin. Okay?
You can put things on your skin because
your skin will absorb a lot of stuff
through through the skin. Okay? It's
another surface area to absorb things.
And so you want to um use our plant
derived minerals in do. Okay. Now we
have a wonderful story about how the
skin saves lives. I mean the skin
literally saves lives. Uh Pastor Mike
Freeman,
okay, from the east coast, big church.
He was in a coma, I know, for six weeks
in a hospital and the doctor calls his
family and says, "Look, um, pastor's got
minutes, maybe hours to live. He he
won't be able to understand you. He's
unconscious. He's been unconscious for
six weeks, but if you want to come and
say your goodbyes, so at least you feel
like you've tried to communicate with
him, you better do it now." Okay? And
so, um, on the way to the hospital, one
of his church members, one of our big
associates with Youngevity, okay, Linda
Tyler, she calls me up and says, "Is
there anything we can do for Pastor
Mike?" And she tells me the situation. I
said, "Well, does he have a G2 so I can
give him something some nutrition that
way?" No. Does he have an IV? We give
him nutrition that way? No. Okay. I just
want you to take a quart bottle or
liquid plant minerals or plant minerals
just extracted from plants. 75 minerals.
And I want you to take a a half a cup, a
half a teac teacup
um three locations, three times a day.
Um
up in the chest, okay? On the sternum,
and the upper belly and the lower belly.
And then three times on the back, okay?
Between the shoulder blades and the
upper back and lower back. Again, just
just with these plant minerals. And
let's see if we can't get them to absorb
them.
Well, in two and a half days,
he wakes up
and he goes to right away he goes to the
church to where they have TV and and
radio studios. He spent 12 hours telling
the world his story about his health
issues and what happened when we rubbed
these plant minerals, God's tools, plant
minerals on them. Okay. And we we
actually made a tool out of that so
everybody can get the story. Okay.
Yes, I do.
>> Oh, well, there you go. Yeah, it's
praise the Lord and pass the 90. Praise
the Lord and pass the 90. It's got that
like those old military things. Praise
the Lord and pass ammunition. You want
to be able to fight back yourself, but
you're also asking the good Lord to
help. So, praise the Lord and and pass
the 90. Okay? Um, and it's one of those
things where um the the the
minerals were totally absorbed and
within weeks he was recovering. I mean
completely in a month or so you wouldn't
even know it was the same guy. Okay. And
of course his story is in this flip
chart that's coming out. It's going to
press tomorrow. Okay. And he he has one
of the great stories in there because
just using our liquid plant minerals on
his skin. It's like intravenous. He
absorbed them almost like introvenously.
And he he had minutes or hours to live
according to the doctors
and church meetings every day, seven
days a week. Well, Pastor Mike, okay,
and his whole team uh is is working that
now. We and we made a tool out of it
because just thank goodness he recorded
his report on the TV cameras and the
radio c um
um recordings.
>> Well, interview with him, Dr. Wallik.
>> Yeah. And and we did an interview with
him. Okay. And so all that's on this DVD
set, DVD and CD set. Praise the Lord and
Pastor 90. My interviews on there with
him. is talking to the general public in
the world uh through all his equipment
at the church. And so this is a great
great great story and it really tells
you the the importance of
minerals, the importance of the skin.
Just think about that. The skin absorbed
all these nutrients so he could live.
These nutrients so he could live. I
mean,
he's got to be kissing on all his skin
all over his whole body, okay? Because
his skin saved his life. And of course,
all his church members, including Miss
Linda, who, you know, um told his wife
and and herself to put these minerals
all over him when he was unconscious.
And um two and a half days later, he
wakes up. And you know, it took him
obviously weeks to totally recover
because I mean, he was near death. Took
him a couple weeks to maybe a month to
totally recover, but he went into a
functional state
in two and a half days after being in a
coma for 6 weeks. And so, you cannot I I
just I get all
uh emotional. I hear that story and tell
the story over and over and over.
And the good lord gave us many many ways
to obtain them. Okay? Including orally,
including through the skin and so on.
Um, now we also have hair, skin, and
nails. Hair, skin, and nails is a
capsule. Okay. It's a capsule or tablet.
I don't remember which. I just take it.
>> It's a capsule.
>> It's a capsule. Yeah. I thought and um
I'm going to increase cuz my hair color
is okay, but I still have some white
hair and my mustache. So, I'm going to
up my hair, skin, and nails. Instead of
um three twice a day, I'm going to do
three three times a day, the hair, skin,
and nails, and see if that doesn't you
know, one other thing I use Zera test X
a- test. It's the raw materials for my
cerolei cells and my um testicles to
make testosterone. We have zerapm for
girls. So if girls have problems with
their skin, they can use the zeraphim
and guys with aerot test. Okay, because
it produces the hormones which uh is
good for all your tissues in your body
including your skin. So, um, with that
said, I I get extremely excited about
the fact that we have tools that work.
We have the nutrition to be employed by
the tools and they work.
And so, with that, I'm going to turn it
over to Rebecca and see if you have any
comments or questions.
>> Well, Dr. Well, like Doc, Pastor Mike
Freeman is just one more story of of
thousands and thousands of stories. Yes.
>> Where you're going from just barely
surviving to thriving.
>> And we have so many stories that that
are untold, Dr. Wallik on the benefits
of the 90 essential nutrients and all of
the work that you have put in to
bringing these products to the to the
world
>> to the world.
>> Not just where you were in Oregon with
your clinics or Mexico with your clinics
or California with your clinics, but
around the world. And yes, folks, Dr.
Wallik, he has had clinics where he was
seeing uh patients in his office and
that just wasn't enough. He wasn't able
to reach the the people and make the
impact in people's healths that he knew
God had called him to do. And that's
when he decided to take on a platform
like Youngevity, create Young with the
marketing that Youngevity offers where
we talk to people all the time and
saying, "Oh, I love this product or I
love this book or have you gone to this
restaurant?" And that's basically what
we do is we're recommending products
that actually work
and instead of just,
you know, the the company or the
restaurant thank you check.
So folks, it's a great system and it's
been given a bad name by some companies,
but Dr. Wallik, I think you were
brilliant in bringing
longevity to the world in a direct sales
type situation because a a product just
sitting on the shelf can't tell you the
story.
>> Yeah. Well, I knew I had to build an
army. That's I was getting interviewed.
Um people were, you know, the reporters
were always asking, "Well, how do you
expect to get this into the world?" I
said, "Well, I'm going to I'm going to
build an army." And their eyes would get
this big. I said, "I'm going to build an
army." And this army is going to take
this information to the world because
even God built an army. God didn't do
everything by himself. God built an army
of angels. Okay? And if God needed to
build an army, we need to build an army.
Okay? The good Lord's example by
building an army. And when we have
something that works, we make sure that
everybody has access to it. And it's one
of those things where we deal with over
600 different diseases and we have 3,000
products. Some of them are, you know,
you have the same product be a liquid, a
pill, and a capsule. Okay. Uh just like
we have the um the uh see here. Oh, the
I26. It's in a chewable, it's in a
capsule, and it's in a powder. Okay.
It's in three arms. There you go. And
that rebuilds your brain and your spinal
cord and the nerve coatings. Okay? And
so if you have diseases like um
Alzheimer disease because a lot of times
when you have a skin issue, that's not
the only issue you have. You can have
Alzheimer's disease and have eczema. You
can have Parkinson's disease and have um
wrinkles
and have uh all kinds of stuff going on
with your skin and your hair. And so you
need an army of trained
people, okay? Um they're almost like
technicians and you train them. And this
is why we have 23 bestselling books
which we're working on for the army. And
of course um this this flip chart is
essentially a different form of a book.
It's it's like a book, but it's in a
form in which um if you even have a
sixth grade reading level, but you want
to give this information to somebody in
your family, four or five people in your
family, or you want to give it to your
workplace or the neighborhood or your
church, um you can you can um be telling
the story to many many people uh with
this flip chart. And if you just read
the story for each of these diseases and
if you're you're giving them information
at the PhD and medical doctor level,
even if you only have a sixth grade,
sixth grade reading level yourself,
>> right? And and Dr. Wallick, a lot of
people don't realize, and this is
something I didn't realize, um my hair
was limp, thin. I mean, I was taking
every time I took my shower, it was
handfuls of hair. Um, I didn't know my
hair could be this curly. I've been sick
so long. And this is all natural, folks.
All natural, natural color, everything.
But one thing that I didn't realize was
my feet, my heels cracked so bad. And I
always had hangails on the sides of my
fingers. And you know, I' I'd pick at
them, cut them, and I'd have bleeding
around my fingernails. My heels were
cracking and bleeding. And that's all
because of nutritional deficiencies.
I that anymore. I don't even have to
think about it. And until I saw a
picture that somebody had sent in
yesterday and I'm like, "Oh, I remember
those days." And I looked down, I'm
like, "I don't have to even think about
that anymore. It's not a concern.
It's just you give the body what it
needs, folks. The body can do some
amazing things without you even thinking
about it, but being intentional on
making sure that you have the right
things going in and keeping the bad
things out.
>> Well said. You're you're going to be
promoted to the next grade.
>> Yes. Love promotions, Dr. Wallik.
Folks, the content of this program is to
provide educational per educational
information on the importance of
nutrition. It is not meant to take the
place of your primary care physician.
The FDA requires us to let you know and
the products that are mentioned are not
meant to treat, diagnose, cure any
diseases. But it's it's medical
community makes it sound difficult. It
gives these long
names that you can't even pronounce,
thinking that, oh goodness, I have
something that's going to end the world.
Well, yeah, if you have that mindset,
it's going to have a poor outcome. But
folks, when you give the body what it
needs, and you have a positive mindset,
knowing that God doesn't create junk,
things are going to look brighter. And
that's where I found the hope that
I needed to keep going. So, Dr. Wallik,
we have lots of hands up. I have lots of
questions coming in through the chats.
And I want to ask a question before we
get into the specific people. Um,
somebody asked a question yesterday that
we didn't get to, and it has to do with
honey. What are your thoughts on honey
as a sweetener?
Okay. Well, honey is a sugar, okay?
Comes from the flowers and the bee
harvests that and form. Okay. And um so
it's it's kind of preserved for uh some
time, but it's a sweetener. Okay. It
does have calories in it, so you can get
some calories out of it. It does have a
few vitamins in there that'll vary from
place to place, a few minerals from
place to place where it's harvested.
But, um you got to watch it. You can't
be using a lot of honey anymore than you
can be using a lot of white sugar, okay?
Because it'll give you the same
problems, okay? There's nothing wrong
with having maybe like a quarter of a
teaspoon
of honey
um uh on your
little gluten-free pancakes in the
morning. They're made out of rice or
made out of
>> a quarter of a teasp. That's just a
teaser.
>> Okay. Well, remember if you start taking
tablespoons of it, you're getting too
much sugar.
>> Yes. Index, which then affects blood
sugar and you raise the blood sugar and
if the body isn't functioning right, it
does damage
no matter what the sweetener is. Right.
>> That's correct. And again, um,
you go back thousands of years ago, the
people who lived the longest came from
the land flowing with milk and honey.
Okay? It wasn't cow's milk or goats milk
or camel's milk. It was glacial milk. It
was ground up rock dust in the streams
coming down from the side of the
mountains. It looked like milk was
white. They didn't have the ability
3,000 years ago to analyze it and
realize it was a mineral source. Chapter
10 of the book rare earth goes into the
land flowing with milk and honey.
Chapter 10, okay, is entitled glacial
milk, okay? And so this is where all
these minerals were coming from for
these people, okay? And the honey part,
why was why was honey always there with
honey? Well, when you have all these
minerals, there were more flowers. And
there were more flowers, there were more
bees. And more bees, more flowers, more
honey. Okay? And so, um, this was the
good lord set up the system so people
would take care of the flowers. They
could sell them. Uh, they had the honey
which they could store, uh, over the
winter time and and have it little bits
at a time. There was something you could
store without refrigeration because it
was so concentrated. It didn't get moldy
or anything like that. But the land
flowing with milk and honey is biblical.
Okay? It goes back um over 3,000 years
ago, 3,000 5,000 years ago. And
the um it's imperative that people know
that the the milk in the land flowing
milk and honey is not the same from
place to place to place because it's
been round up by the glaciers. Okay. And
so in that chapter 10 of the book rarest
been cures the ch you know glacial milk
we have analyses I don't know maybe a
half a dozen different glacial milks and
some of them have three minerals some
have 15 some have 25 some have 40 some
have 50 some have 75 they're not all
exactly the same okay and so some lands
flung with milk and honey were kind of
hoham for longevity but the ones that
had 50 minerals 75 minerals so those are
the ones that had the long life.
>> So, we've got a question out on YouTube
and KK wants to know, "What what do you
recommend to eat when they crave sweet
stuff or something sweet?" So, let's
talk real quick about cravings, Dr.
Wallik.
>> Okay. Well, cravings uh is called pah p
i ca. Look up the word pah. Pah is when
you're craving,
okay, where you're chewing on the fence.
Uh this is why people get obese. They're
trying to eat something. They're trying
to find something that's going to
satisfy these cravings. Okay? And so um
when you have these cravings, that means
you are minally deficient.
It's like the red warning light, the
dashboard of your car when you have
these cravings.
Okay. PHA craving.
>> Okay. So you if you've got cravings and
it doesn't matter does it matter, Dr.
Wall, if it's a sweet craving or a salty
craving.
>> No, it doesn't matter.
>> Greasy food craving.
>> It doesn't matter.
>> All right. Because I know I know it's
possible because you know I had those
things and you're absolutely right, Dr.
Well, when I started putting the
minerals into my body, those cravings
went away so I could make wiser choices
and and the weight fell off. So, I'm
down 100 pounds as of right now, and I'm
very thankful for that. And it's the
nutrition, Dr. Wellik, and the food
choices, not a whole lot of extrrenuous
exercise that got me to where I'm at.
I I am happy about that. So, thank you,
Doc.
>> Well, going back to the Bible days, you
know, 3,000 years ago, um, in the Old
Testament, there's 21 stories about the
land flowing with milk and honey.
There's 21 stories. They range from two
paragraphs to two pages in length. And
then there's a hundred mentions in the
Old Testament where they're talking
about a person for a reason. They say,
"Oh, they came from the land flowing
with milk and honey." There's a hundred
mentions like that.
Okay. So, it was it was well known that
there was some relationship between the
land flowing with milk and honey and
long healthful lives.
So there's significance to that land
flowing with milk and honey, folks.
>> Oh yes,
>> mentioned that many times. There is
significance.
Well, Dr. Wick, let's go to some
questions. And the first question that I
want to ask is coming in um from Coach
Rod. He has a 51 year old female 5 foot
five
pounds with lupus and scarcidosis.
No blood pressure issues issues. Dr.
Wallik, let's talk about lupus and
scarcidosis.
>> Is it sarcoidosis?
>> Exactly what you said. Isn't that what I
said?
>> Okay. All right.
Well, both of those are nutritional
deficiences. Doctors will call them
autoimmune. Your body's attacking
itself. Okay. And lupus, uh, you get
skin problems, you get digestive
problems, you get respiratory problems,
and doctors say, "See, your body's
attacking itself." No,
you're missing nutrients. And so, here's
a case where you want to get a hair
analysis and find out exactly what
you're missing. Get that book again. Um,
rare cures, chapter 10, glacial milk. It
tells you how to collect the hair. Uh, I
think starts at page 272.
Okay,
there you go. And
>> use it so often, Dr. Wallick. I just
have it bookmarked. And you're
absolutely 272.
>> Well, there you go. And so I've I've
looked at it a few times.
And so once you start taking these
nutrients and staying away from the bad
stuff, lupus can go away. I don't care
if you've had it for 5 10 years and
doctors are kind of dampening down the
symptoms of cortisone and prennazone
that kind of stuff but they're not
getting ready to the basic root cause
and saridosis
is scar tissue sarcoids is scar tissue
okay and it can be from many
deficiencies including the same ones
that are involved with lupus and it
depends on what you're eating which you
get you get lupus or do you get
saridosis you can have both at the same
time. Saridosis is particularly um um
normal tissue being replaced with scar
tissue.
Okay. In lupus, your bone marrow is all
messed up. Okay? Uh because it's not
getting the nutrients it needs. Uh skin
problems. Uh also bowel problems and
loops. You could have both of them at
the same time, but doctors want to throw
them into autoimmune diseases where the
body's attacking itself or are genetic
or both. Okay, it's not just simple
nutritional deficiencies.
>> So, throwing a steroid at it to suppress
the immune system's natural response, is
that the right thing to do?
No, because but it's what the doctors do
because in three days all the itching
and pain and stuff like that will be
subdued and maybe even gone. Oh, I just
love my doctor. I mean, I had this for
years and nobody got it diagnosed. My
doctor diagnosed it as as an autoimmune
disease. He gave me this cortisone
prennazone and in three days time all my
symptoms are gone and then three months
later they'll die
>> because they didn't get the nutrition
was necessary to make everything work
properly.
So what do you re for somebody that is
dealing with lupus and scarcidosis?
>> Sarcoy sarcoidosis.coyidosis.
>> Sarcoidosis. Yeah. Well, they need to
get rid of all the bad foods. No fried
foods, no processed meats, no oils, no
glutens, no wheat, no ran oats, no
buckwheat, no sugar, no carbonated
drinks. Even the diet drinks and
carbonated water need to go. Then per
100 pounds of body weight and this gal
weighed what? What? 160 pounds.
>> 160 pounds. She needs two healthy brain
and heart packs a month. Full doing
twice a day. She needs two bottles a
month. The MSM. So you can take three at
breakfast, three lunch, dinner time. And
they're going to support and promote
maintenance repair of cartilage,
ligaments, tendons, connective tissue,
disc between vertebrae, bone ras, bone
itself. Um let's see here bone marrow.
So make white blood cells and
antibodies. uh and also um to um
help you um make um red blood cells for
carrying oxygen around and platelets so
they don't bleed to death. Okay. And how
long do you have to stay on the 90% lip?
Okay. Uh this is not something you take
while you have a problem and then when
the problem subsides or goes away, okay,
I can stop taking all this stuff now.
I'm just go back to, you know, my doctor
says just eat right. I don't get
everything I need. No, that's not true.
Any doctor who says that should have
their license suspended for at least a
year and they should be put into a
training course, kind of a a jail with a
training course. So, you can't see
patients anymore for a year because um
these things are reversible. They're
preventable. They're not genetic. Um we
have three people in our family with it.
Well, do they all live in the same
county? Well, they all live in the same
house. Well, they're all eating
grandma's recipes and she didn't have
the problem. Okay. Well,
there you go.
>> There you go. So,
Healthy Brain and Heart Pack,
MSM Ultra,
>> Collagen,
Ultimate Daily Classic,
and take the nutrition throughout the
body. And it wouldn't hurt to throw in
the um uh rebound or sports drink
instead of you know soft drinks and that
kind of stuff.
>> Well, and the I26
>> I26 absolutely
makes it makes the collagen it makes the
>> um
the white matter in the brain and the
spinal cord and all the coverings of the
nerves.
>> Yep. Absolutely. Plus, it takes care of
all those bad pathogens, folks, that can
be hiding within the digestive system,
keeping the food from breaking down and
keeping the body from being able to um
thrive also. So, I absolutely love the
functions of the I26.
Well, Dr. Wallik, um we're going to go
to the first the hands that are up right
now. And folks, if you are on the phone,
there's an option where you can raise
your hand also. So if you do star six
that mutes and unmutes you but if you do
star nine that raises your hand and do
star n go all the way to South Africa
and
Albert go ahead and unmute yourself. You
have a question for Dr. Wallik.
>> Good evening Dr. Wallik. I hope you're
doing well.
>> Oh yes sir. Thank you.
My question is,
>> doctor, my question is that when
somebody has been on gluten their whole
life and they decide to um get off
gluten, what happens within the
intestine that starts removing the uh
the gluten from the intestine so that
the veli can grow back?
>> Okay. Well, the gluten in the intestines
um is something that kind of moves
through the intestines. there'll be a
certain amount stored there, but there's
a turnover. Your intestinal villi are
constantly trying to um have babies, you
know, have baby villi to replace the
ones that have been killed by the
gluten. And so,
um that kicks in and suddenly now all
those villi start growing again. And you
know, you can see results within maybe a
week or two weeks. Um and then within
months it's like you're home free.
>> No, that's wonderful. Thanks,
>> doctor.
Great.
>> All right. Thank you, gentlemen, for
that little bit of um conversation
there, too. And now we have to go look
it up and figure out what exactly did
they say?
>> It was in Africans. have a great day.
Yeah.
>> Um
>> and stuff like that. So, Marilyn, go
ahead and unmute yourself. You have a
question for Dr. Wallik today.
Unmute yourself, Marilyn. Okay. Hi,
everybody. Say you were talked talked
about, you had said something about
biopsies a little bit. Can you go into a
little bit more detail the difference
between the biopsy results versus a hair
analysis? Because you said the biopsy,
why is it not um significant results as
opposed to the hair analysis?
>> Okay. Well, a biopsy of the skin um
doesn't give you
um an analysis of the mineral content of
the skin. It'll tell you if you have
cancer. It'll tell you you have scar
tissue, that kind of stuff. Um whereas
the hair analysis
uh gives you all the nutritional
minerals that are in your hair, all the
toxic minerals are in your hair, you
can't get from a blood test, okay, or a
biopsy. That's why we came up with a
hair analysis.
>> Fantastic. Thank you.
>> All right. Thank you, Marilyn. And next,
let's move right over to Malcolm.
Malcolm, go yourself.
>> Can you hear me? Yes, sir.
>> Yes, sir.
>> All righty. Yeah, I'm 71 years old. Uh
about 5'9, 155 pounds. Been pretty
healthy all my life because I've been
taking vitamins and minerals for a long
time. Um I've got what's called fuchsia.
My opthalmologist says I need a cornea
transplant. Just wondering what could
help with that.
>> I'm sorry. My blood pressure.
>> Wait a minute. Back up a minute. Back up
a minute. What What drophe do you have?
Fuches
f u c hs
>> fucistrophe. Okay. And how does that
manifest itself?
>> Uh he says the cells in my cornea are
dying. They're supposed to pump liquid
out of the cornea. They're not. So I got
like
>> it's an eye disease.
>> It's an eye.
>> Okay.
>> Right.
>> Do you have any ringing in your ears?
>> No.
>> Do you have any balance problems?
>> Occasionally. Yes.
>> Okay. Of course, 71 years old. I guess
that just comes with it, but anyway.
Yeah.
>> No, no, it doesn't come with age. Okay.
What um how many times you wake up at
night to urinate? Once, three times,
five times?
>> Uh two to three, I guess, depending on
how much I drink.
>> Okay.
Do you have any high blood pressure,
diabetes?
>> Blood pressure is running around uh 140
over 75, 150 over 75, somewhere around
there. No diabetes.
Okay. All right. Yeah, you might want to
get an MRI of your skull and see if you
have osteoporosis of the skull. Um
because when you get, you know, a little
balance problems, you get maybe some
ring in the ears, you get stuff going on
your eyes, the skull, when you have
osteoporosis of the skull, if you can
show that, Becca, the the skull gets
thicker and it squeezes those nerves,
including the optic nerve. And so they
look at the eye and they can't see
anything really wrong with the eye, but
the skull is squeezing that optic nerve,
optic vein, causing those problems.
That's a normal skull, quarter inch
thick, looking down on the brain at
autopsy. Okay, up. You have to raise it
now a little bit. Raise it more. More.
Raise it more. There you go. That one
also autopsy. The top of the skull is
you're looking down in the brain, but
you see that inch and a half
>> thick.
Okay. Squeezing those 12 cranial nerves.
Now, that is not bone. That is scar
tissue because the bone is gone. Okay?
This is osteoporosis of the skull. And
you need to get a hold of this book.
It's all in your head. It's a book in a
CD set, okay? Which these pictures are
in.
And there's a chapter uh for each of the
cranial nerves. And then the CD is for
the spinal cord. And there's aboutund
um 30 diseases you can get when you have
osteoporosis of the skull. Okay. And so
you've got several of them. And so I I
would be looking at that. So um your
body weight is
pounds. Yeah. 155 pounds. None of the
bad foods, no fried foods, no processed
meats, no oils, no glutens, no wheat, no
rin oats, no buckwheat, no sugar, no
carbonated drinks. Even the diet drinks
and carbonated water need to go. And
then 155 pounds, two healthy brain and
heart packs per month. A full dose I
think twice a day. Two bottles a month
of the MSM. So you can take um uh three
at breakfast lunch at dinner time and
they're going to support and promote
major repair of cartilage, ligaments,
tendons, connective tissue, discs
between vertebrae, bone ras, bone cell,
skin, all kinds of stuff. Okay? And then
um you also
need to take the collagen peptides, take
a scoop of that with your morning drink,
scoop with the evening drink. I would
also uh throw in the uh let's see here.
I would go with the
let's see here the brain. We need brain
stuff. What what brain stuff would you
give somebody here, Becca?
>> Well, Dr. Wallock, I think you mentioned
the Synaptive. If not, Synaptive and
then we also have Renew IQ, which is an
amazing, it's yummy tasting drink mix.
>> Okay. Renew IQ. Okay. And um there you
go. And so you do all those things. Um
the I26
um it helps rebuild the brain, okay? And
the milein, the white matter of the
brain and the spinal cord. And you're
going to see benefit, okay? But you're
going to have to do these things. You
just can't you just can't say, "Well,
you know, I've got some stuff going on
uh here and I'll just um go to the
doctor and get a cortisone shot." That's
not going to work.
No. Um, also my skin tears easily and I
bruise easily.
>> Okay. Well, that's where again you want
to be sure you're getting the um
collagen.
>> You want to get the collagen peptides.
You want to get a hold of the gluccoel.
Okay. And rebuild the skin. Forget the
um hair, skin, and nails. Hair, skin,
and nails. Got stuff like that going on.
You want to take at least three of those
twice a day. You might want to take
three three times a day until things get
better. Then you can take three twice a
day for maintenance. But I'd go with
three three times a day
and um
kind of go in that direction. Want to
give your body a source what it needs
because it's not true. You can get
everything you need just by eating well.
That's not true. Plants
>> cannot make minerals. Plants do make
vitamins, amino acids, fatty acids,
okay? But plants do not make minerals
and minerals make up two/irds of the 90
essential nutrients. Okay?
When I can um if I exercise vigorously
real quick, like when I play with the
dog for 10 minutes, I get out not 10
minutes, 15 seconds, I get out of
breath, but yet I can go on a a two-mile
walk or five mile bike ride with no
problems.
>> That's the type of exercise you're
doing. Okay. But we do have Oxybody.
Okay. Okay, we have rebounders for
shrink. I I would throw the rebound in
there. Okay, we have the sticks. We have
the canister. We do have the cans. If
you're going to use the cans, you got to
pop the tops on the night before put in
the refrigerator so all the carbonation
is gone by morning. If you need
something quick, the um rebound and the
sticks. Okay, there's 30 sticks in a
box. We have the canister. There's 36
servings uh in in the canister, but
there's no uh there's no um um
carbonation in there, so that's good.
That'll help. Yeah. Okay.
>> Well, if I may interrupt real quick. So,
when he's doing a walk, he's upright and
straight. when he's bending down playing
with the dog, he's causing
pressure on some nerves that could be
going on, which would just be kind of
more of a osteoporosis of the skull.
>> And I know from listening, the nerves go
to the heart, they go to the lungs,
which could both either one of them
could cause some shortness of breath and
lack of energy. Is that
is that a good assessment?
>> Yeah, and that's why I recommend the
rebound.
>> All right.
>> Also, since since you bring that up, it
is interesting sometimes if I just, you
know, just look up with my head, I get
dizzy.
>> Yeah, I I'd get that an MRI,
okay, of your skull because the odds are
you have osteoporosis skull. Do you have
anything going on with your um heart
rate? Do you have an irregular heart
rate or fast heart rate?
No.
>> Okay, good. Okay, I apologize that time.
>> Yeah, you've got to go, Dr. Wallik.
Thank you so much, Malcolm, for your
question. Great question. Dr. Wallik, we
will see you tomorrow on Daily with Doc.
Um, folks, you are watching Daily with
Doc Doc. Thank you so much for joining
us here. If I could get my co-hosts up,
that would be fantastic. as I am getting
Dr. Wallik out of the room so he can
move on to his next program. Um because
folks, he's a busy busy man and we don't
want to keep somebody else waiting for
him. So my co-hosts, I could not do this
without them. We got Sherry Browning who
is helping let people in. She's helping
put information and watching the the
chat and also on different platforms
watching questions that are coming in
from there as well. And we had questions
that we did not get to. I apologize
we're limited on time. So please go to
our website dailywithdoc.com.
Use that contact option and we will get
some answers to you using Dr. Wallik's
recommendations. and we have the ability
to do like so we'll get his
recommendations for you. And folks,
there's a lot of times where the doc the
protocol that Dr. Wallik recommends just
doesn't fit somebody's budget. We have
been trained to be able to use what your
what's going on, what your goals are,
and tailor make something specifically
for you that's going to help you reach
your goals. Maybe not as fast as what
Dr. Wallik is recommending with the
optimal recommendations, but folks, the
body can do some amazing things. So,
Sherry, thank you so much for doing
that. Sorry, I take that bunny trail.
Um, Marilyn, who is putting in the chat
just dictation of what Dr. Wallik
recommends plus other information that
is helpful and beneficial that gives you
tools in your toolbox to be able to make
air with others to help them. So, thank
you so much Marilyn for doing that. We
have Albert way down in South Africa
bringing in questions like he did today.
some great questions that a lot of
people are thinking about and just
aren't here to ask. So, we'll be able to
use these questions as well and answer
questions that people have. But Albert,
thank you so much for just having a
heart for people and being here with us
um even when it's not convenient hours.
So, thank you, Albert. And we have the
assistant executive production manager
AJ who is here making sure that
everything is going in the right
direction, bringing in questions as he's
watching the different platforms as well
and
just really helping us make this the
best program we possibly can and as we
can. And folks, that's where you can
come into play. Also, you're not hearing
this program just by chance. There is a
purpose. And I truly believe that you
know somebody that this
information can benefit. So share this
information with those around you.
You're on social media. We have a
giveaway that will give you points that
will then could possibly
end you up with some free products. As
I'm doing this giveaway, those who share
the program, they first you have to go
to dwdgiveaway.com.
That's dwdgiveaway.com.
Sign up for the giveaway and click the
different platforms that you are on. But
make sure that you go to that platform,
look us to our channels and hey, leave
us a comment. Let us know that you are
there. We love to know where we are
reaching around the world. So, make sure
you sign up for the giveaway. And folks,
again, if you were referred to this
program by somebody specific, please
make sure that you get back with them.
If not, then we have an amazing team
here at Daily with Doc and a phone team
if you call 8559493377.
This is for those in Canada and United
States. If you're on WhatsApp, um, make
sure that you go to dailywithdoc.com,
use that uh, contact option and let us
know that you're on WhatsApp. submit
your questions there and we will have
somebody reach out to you and help you
figure out what is needed and how to get
it to you. So, thank you so much. My
name is Becca Dukes and it is my honor
and privilege to bring to you empowering
information that actually works. Bye for
now.
Heat. Heat.